at what point in your career did you go
without work for
was it a year okay what happened
yeah that was in 2009 and
that contact that one connection that i
had made helped me get that first show
but i didn't have like a huge rolodex of
people that i knew in the industry so
it was really challenging to book
another job because
you know as from a graphic designer
standpoint you really need to know
people you know one once you get into
the union there is an availability list
that you can put yourself on and you can
get some jobs from
your name being on the availability list
but people are only going to that list
until they've you know they've gone
through they've exhausted their list of
people they know
so it's so much about who you know and i
just didn't know enough people yet you
know
my pool was so small so um
i i had you know it was like the worst
year of my life because it was also the
recession and so i couldn't even get a
waitressing job
like i remember this one day where i saw
craigslist posting for
a waitress interview a server interview
and i got my car right away and drove
right over and there were already like
10 people in line and they were only
taking one person
so it that was really challenging too
and like i really
you know even now i try to get better
but i tend to tie myself worth to how
much money i have
and so when i like couldn't even make a
living
as like getting a server job or
something like that or any kind of side
job
um it and and this was also before uber
and lyft existed you know i couldn't
drive for instacart i couldn't i
couldn't do those things it couldn't be
a postmates person
um and so that was really hard for me
too
so not only like struggling to find the
work but then time my worth
to that and and feeling so unworthy of
success or anything that i wanted that
was really hard
how well do you remember the depression
that you faced oh gosh
i very well because i still experience
it all the time like
i'm i think i'm prone to depression i
call it situational depression because
it usually comes from a situation so
something happens
um to cause me to be depressed i don't
normally feel it just
to feel it with no trigger um so i
recall it very well because i felt it
again
many times since then um
but it was just a really pivotal time in
my life like i remember it
so well so well
i can really connect you know to those
feelings and
[Music]
you know what i tried to do you know
just all the things that i did and
even though it was almost 13 years ago
at this point 12 years ago
i i still remember it very clearly
yeah it was a really rough time for a
lot of people yes it was and i mean
thank god i didn't have kids or didn't
have a home you know so many people lost
their homes and
you know much worse than you know
fortunately i was able to
stay afloat and you know i had two
roommates at the time and so i was able
to still stay in la which is
amazing it could have been much worse
but yeah it was a tough time
how are you able to book a job at the
end of all that i asked
for help it was so
hard i my cousin told me a story
um it's a short story i can tell it
quickly
and people probably heard it before i
forget
all the details but essentially there
was a man
in his house and it started raining and
as the rain came down it didn't stop and
it started to flood
and he was like oh my gosh how am i
going to be okay
and he just kept praying to god god save
me
i will be okay please help me god and
the flood kept growing and the rain was
getting worse and so he goes to the
upstairs in his house so he can get to
the next level because it's starting to
come into his house
and he sees um someone in their truck
drives by and they're like hey man we
can help you
come jump in the truck and he was like
no god will save me i'm going to go
upstairs to this upper level i will be
fine
and then the rain keeps coming and the
flood is rising
and someone in a boat passes by
and they're like hey jump in the boat
we'll help you we'll save you they see
him in this window you know jump out of
your wind
and he's like no i'll be okay i'm
praying god will save me
and then finally it becomes like
unbearable and he has to literally climb
to the roof
of his house and a helicopter comes
and flies over and drops a ladder and
says you know
we grab the ladder we can save you i
said no
god will save me i prayed and i know god
will save me
and the water rose so much that he
couldn't go anywhere and he ended up
drowning
and died and he goes to heaven
and he's like god what the heck i prayed
for you to save me why didn't you save
me
and god said i sent you a truck i sent
you a boat
i sent you a helicopter
and when my cousin told me that story
it really helped me see that
like if you're drowning it's okay to ask
for help you know i felt very ashamed
of where i was you know in my life and
how much i was struggling because again
i really tied it to my self-worth and i
just thought
you know i'm not a good enough human
being i don't deserve this and so i
don't even deserve somebody's help you
know
and i would ghost people's texts you
know i just wouldn't even respond to
friends
texts or calls because i was so ashamed
i was so embarrassed
you know if they say how are you what's
going on and i would say nothing
nine months later and still nothing is
going on you know i was so ashamed
so after my cousin told me that story
i was like okay and so i reached out to
one of
the girls that i had become friendly
with from the first show
and i told her look i really need a job
if you know of anyone looking because
she was the same age as me but she had
already been in the industry longer and
she knew a lot of people and so she had
found other work
i said i really need a job if you hear
of anything could you let me know
and she heard of something and she
recommended me and it was glee
and they called me
and they called me a week after i
finally got a waitressing job
a week after and i was like
you have no idea how much i want to come
work for you but it was to fill in for
somebody for
just a couple days and i was like
you have no idea how badly i want to say
yes to you
but i just spent like eight or nine
months with no job
and i just got this waitressing job a
week ago i don't think i can quit this
for just a couple days work
even though i really want to and so i
said
like if something else comes up longer
term please please call me
and a month later they did and they
called me and they said
now we need someone to fill in for the
rest of the season and i gave my notice
after a month of waitressing and i went
and worked on glee
wow because that goes back to that
energy shift and so
here you had something you finally got a
waitressing job
after you know racing down to an open
call for one
and then then this other one opened up
so that goes back to what you're talking
about earlier
definitely i mean even just getting the
waitressing job
it filled me up so much you know and
not even just self-worth and feeling
like wow okay i finally have some money
coming in i can survive and
and i have a job but also being around
other people you know because
i was so afraid to spend money that i
wouldn't leave my room
i would stay in my room in my apartment
like all day every day i was afraid to
leave
because it would cost me money to leave
and
i just i wasn't around people and so
that i think also helped to be around
people
and you know waitressing your your
hustling and walking fast and something
so i was getting exercise again and
moving my body
you know all of these things that were
beneficial that i think
really shifted my energy than to be open
for
a tv show very interesting
wow what a story so so when you got the
waitressing job
how did that feel because i realized
that wasn't your ultimate destination
no it wasn't but i was elated you know i
just needed something
i hadn't had any work in so long i i was
so so happy and so grateful to get that
waitressing job
yes wow do you ever go back to that
restaurant well then know now you
probably can't because it's just takeout
if it's still around right well
so that so it's funny because so it's on
the block
near where i live so i could walk there
and i
felt so guilty about like leaving after
just a month and i
could tell the manager was not happy
with me that on glee i was an assistant
and i was in charge of getting lunch
every day
so i would always say hey we should go
to this restaurant and so i gave them
business and we would order from the
whole office and order lunch there and i
would go there and pick it up
because i wanted to still give them
business you know because i felt so bad
about leaving
um and so and i and that restaurant was
amazing food so good
but it doesn't exist anymore and another
restaurant is in its place now that's
also a very good restaurant and i go
there when it's open yes that's a great
story and
and and even the staff like the people
in the kitchen and the other servers
like
some of them i still talk to you to this
day some of them went to the restaurant
next door and i always say hi i get so
excited to see them and
it's nice
you